you prefer the basic idea is that the Z stabilizer generators detect X errors
but they're completely oblivious to Z errors because Z stabilizer generators always commute with Z
errors in addition the Z stabilizer generators also commute with whatever Z Gates we might choose to apply as
Corrections for Z errors similarly the X stabilizer generators detect Z errors but they're completely
oblivious to X errors and Corrections so we can in essence think about the Z stabilizer generators as representing a
classical linear code that protects against bit flips or in other words x errors well the X stabilizer generators
represent a classical linear code in the plus minus basis that completely independently protects against flips
between plus and minus States or in other words phase flip errors or Z errors so now it's quite apparent what's going
on with the steam code it's simply a 743 hemming code for bit flip errors and a 743 Hamming code for phas flip
errors once again the fact that the Z stabilizer generators and X stabilizer generators commute is required it
wouldn't be a valid stabilizer code if they didn't and you could say that it's good fortune that the 743 Heming code
works out like this but there are a lot of other choices that can be made for pairs of classical linear codes that will give us a valid stabilizer code
when combined in this way now getting back to CSS codes in general suppose that the Z stabilizer
generators allow for the correction of up to say JX errors and the X stabilizer generators allow for the correction of
up to k z errors so in the case of the steing code J and K are both one because
the 743 hemming code can correct one bit flip but in general these numbers J and K could be different
it then follows by the discretization of errors that the CSS code can correct for any error on a number of cubits up to
the minimum of J and K that's because when we measure the syndrome an arbitrary error on some
number of cubits effectively collapses probabilistically into some combination of X errors Z errors or both and then
the X errors and Z errors can be detected and corrected independently so as long as we have two
classical linear codes that get along in the sense that they give us x and z stabilizer generators that commute the
CSS code we get by combining them basically inherits the error correction properties of the two codes in the sense that I've just
described notice that there is a price to be paid though which is that we can't encode as many cubits as we could bits
with the two classical codes because the total number of stabilizer generators for the CSS code is the sum of the
number of parody checks for the two classical codes and each stabilizer generator cuts the dimension of the codee space in
half for example the 743 Hamming code allows for the encoding of four classical bits because we have just
three parody checks for this code whereas the 7 Cubit steam code only encodes one cubit because it has six
stabilizer generators the last thing I'll explain about CSS codes in general in this lesson concerns code spaces of CSS codes
and what they look like and this will also give us a chance to examine in a little bit more detail the relation relationship that needs to hold between
two classical linear codes in order for them to be compatible in that we can combine them together to form a CSS
code consider an arbitrary CSS code on N cubits and let Z1 through Zs be the nbit
parity check strings that correspond to the Z stabilizer generators this means that the classical
linear code described by the Z stabilizer generators which we'll call CZ just to help us to remember that this
is the code corresponding to the Z stabilizer generators takes the form that's shown here on the screen in words the code contains every
string U whose binary do product with each of the parody check strings is zero well if we wanted to we could also
consider a different code derived from these same strings which we'll call DZ and the idea here is that we think about
these strings Z1 through Zs not as parity check strings but rather as generators
at this point it isn't clear why we would want to think about this code but we can and it'll turn out to be relevant to this
discussion this code is called the Dual code of CZ and it's commonly denoted CZ per meaning CZ with the perpendicular
symbol as a superscript but we're going to call it DZ and that'll be easy enough to remember because D is short for
dual we can also do something similar with the X stabilizer generators so this time CX is the classical linear code
whose parity check strings correspond to the X stabilizer generators and DX is the Dual code of this code as an aside
we can now describe the conditions that must hold in order for CZ and CX to be compatible in the sense that we can
paare them together as a CSS code in terms of these codes themselves specifically it must be that
DZ is contained in CX or equivalently that DX is contained in CZ and now it's
possible to describe the code space of the CSS code derived from these two codes and one way to describe it is that
it's the space Spann by all of the vectors that take the form that's shown on the screen in words they look like uniform
superpositions over the strings in the Dual code DX of the code corresponding to the X stabilizer generators shifted
by or exord with strings in the code CZ corresponding to the Z stabilizer generators and we'll see what this looks
like in the specific case of the steam code in just a moment this makes sense because states in the code space must be
plus one igen vectors of all the stabilizer generators and in particular multiplying by any one of the X
stabilizer generators is equivalent to xoring by the corresponding X string so that's why these uniform superpositions
over DX shifted by different strings appear like this different choices for the shift
represented by the string Y in this expression can give us the same vector by the way so these states aren't all distinct but collectively they expan the
entire code space there is a symmetry here between the x and z stabilizer generators and
the codes that they correspond to and so we can use that symmetry to describe vectors in the code space in an analogous way swapping x's and Z's but
we also need to swap the standard bases for the plus minus bases which is why the hatam operations appear in this
expression now for the example that was promised which is the steam code we end up with these two encoded as possible
encodings of the zero and one standard basis States in particular we can encode the zero State as a uniform
superposition over the eight strings in the Dual code of the 743 Hamming code which turns out to be half of the strings in the 743 Hamming code and we
can encode the one state in a similar way except that all the strings are exor by the all one string in this case